[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Ross Tucker joining us on behalf of
DraftKings DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app today use the promo code Patrick for
a special offer when you sign up promo
code Patrick only at DraftKings
Sportsbook and uh Ross Tucker said to
join us there he is oh popped up on the
screen you scared me a little bit it's
like that scene in Animal House when
flounder the picture of Flounder shows
up and they all go
ah there's Ross
um well you know what though Dan they
got him in the fraternity anyway because
his dad went there or whatever Legacy
like me even if you don't want me
DraftKings got me in the day so I'm in
here anyway yeah flounder's brother was
a legacy all right uh let me start with
the Steelers
can you have a good loss if you're
Pittsburgh considering that you brought
in Kenny Pickett to replace Mitchell
trubisky
no I mean I I think there are some
losses that are better than others but I
would say no for this dealers for a
couple reasons Dan Mike Tomlin has never
had a losing record you know that
organization just looks at things
differently than a lot of others do they
never give up on a year they never give
up on a game and I think it's great that
they put Pickett in he did provide a
spark but you're up 20 to 10 in the
second half against the New York Jets
and you let Zach Wilson lead 270 plus
yard touchdown drives you're the
Pittsburgh Steelers at home and you're
getting sliced and yeah but good in a
way that you've made the change to Kenny
Pickett
not that you in your defense that's
inexcusable that you allow the Jets to
come back in Pittsburgh but Kenny
Pickett is maybe now your quarterback
moving forward is that a good thing even
though it was in a loss yeah I would say
it's a terrible loss but that is the
positive Silver Lining that Pickett did
provide a spark okay in more ways than
one yes all right that's what I was
trying to do you know you made it far
more complicated
um help me understand John Harbaugh's
logic here at the end of that game
against Buffalo
yeah I think he at that point did not
have a ton of confidence in his
defense's ability
to prevent the bills from getting a
field goal and tying it going overtime
and I think he thought on the two yard
line I'm going to show some faith in
Lamar because either we get a touchdown
and then it greatly increases our
chances to win the game or
it's incomplete pass or we don't score
the bills have to go the length of the
field they're at the two yard line I
don't think when he did the calculation
and I've talked to these teams Dan I
know you do too they have all the win
probability stuff probably they they
know if the bills get the ball at the
two like they know all of the different
win probability factors I don't think
they took into account Lamar throwing a
pick and the bills getting the ball at
the 20. because there's a big difference
in terms of play calling and mindset
when you start to drive at the two
versus the 20. although you know what I
mean the bills marched down and could
have easily scored a touchdown anyway I
mean they were able to get the one yard
line why didn't the Ravens let him score
why didn't they let him score to get the
ball back then
I think they were trying to I think the
the I I think that might be why Marcus
Peters was so fired up wait a minute
they couldn't stop them the entire game
and then you tell them just to let them
score and then they stop them
I think I I think the one play when the
guy ran to the one yard line he went
down though like the bills figured it
out I think they were even trying to let
him score there yeah and it must have
been Singletary I don't think he was
really trying to score and obviously the
bills very very smartly knew we don't
want score touchdown we don't want to
get the ball back we can take the clock
all the way down it was perfect Dan
because I had the Ravens plus three and
a half so the bills get the win the
Ravens still cover it was it was a
beautiful ending to that football game
all right the Eagles went down but not
out came back bad weather Trevor
Lawrence with fumbles but you know a
little bit tougher game probably than
Philadelphia or we thought it might be
but uh you're comfortable with the
Eagles are they the best team in the NFC
right now
I think they are and I I'm not sure
there's a team in the NFL that has a
better roster than them right now it's
really unbelievable I mean they go out
in free agency and get Hassan Reddick he
has two strip sacks of Trevor Lawrence
in the fourth quarter I mean exactly why
Howie Roseman went out and got him as a
free agent the one thing they hadn't
done so far this year Dan was really
have to overcome adversity
how about a pick six from Hertz how
about down 14 nothing in the first
quarter of your former coach all they
did after that adversity will score the
next 29 Points to go up
29-14 thoroughly impressed by this
Eagles team and they certainly handled
the rain a lot better than Trevor
Lawrence I mean he had four fumbles Dan
two of them were unfortunate I thought
he had big hands I don't know what
happened to Trevor Lawrence with all the
fumbles but that was a very impressive
win by The Eagles I mean they're doing
that that's four straight really
impressive wins by the Eagles
but if the Eagles went up against the
bills
or went up against Kansas City
or anybody else
who would you take in in those matchups
well I think I think those are probably
I'd love to see the betting line at
DraftKings for those games because I
think those are pretty much push games
right now I'd love to see what the line
would be my guess is the Eagles would be
slight underdogs because of Josh Allen
because of Patrick Mahomes who were both
ridiculous again yesterday
but the Eagles have an awfully good team
the question now is
how bad were the injuries they suffered
they lost 2-0 linemen yesterday slay
only played three snaps so the injuries
might be getting them a little bit but
it's interesting Dan because that is the
company that they're in right now I mean
I think in my mind the three teams in
the AFC are the Ravens Bills and Chiefs
and I think the Eagles are kind of right
up there with them in terms of teams
that are looking like they have a legit
chance to go to the Super Bowl feels
like the Rams played opening night and
we haven't really talked about the Rams
since then
uh feels like they're still formidable
now you have the Niners game tonight
what do you expect out of this
yeah it's a good point because they
played a couple non-descript games
Sunday afternoon people haven't really
been paying attention to them but
they've won a couple in a row uh I love
some of the stuff that Sean mcbay's
doing basically puts a wide receiver Ben
scaronic at fullback now in the last
game that was awesome this is a gut
check time for Kyle Shanahan I mean I
know there's some people in San
Francisco that think the Niners
organization should potentially move on
from him they told me that on the radio
last week that really stunned me really
but they were pathetic against the
Broncos this is a Monday night game you
know the way it is Dan The Prime Time
games are like 10 times as important in
the court of public opinion no Trent
Williams they need to play much much
better because if the Rams win and I
kind of like the Rams in this game
tonight there's going to start to be
some interesting chatter in San
Francisco around Kyle Shanahan
well not quite sure what you have at
quarterback here I know it's Jimmy G and
yes all he does is win but bigger
picture here you know the Niners went
all in on Trey Lance and it's sort of
like Jimmy's still hanging around it's
like all right I don't have a date for
the dance I'll dance with you for a
little while I wonder if they have a
quarterback as they move on uh you know
this entire season into next season
it feels like there's a myriad of
possibilities right now for them right
like Jimmy could play really well and
they bring him back
um Jimmy could play terrible and they
move on and they and it's Trey Lance's
job I guess I feel like at this point
it almost would be hard to go into next
year with only Trey Lance it feels like
they'd almost have to give themselves
another option and that might be the
thing that helps Shanahan out the most
even if the Niners have a down year is
ownership probably wants to at least
have one year where they can see what
Kyle Shanahan does with the guy they
traded up to get the number three
overall pick the draft
we're talking to Ross Tucker joining us
on behalf of DraftKings host of even
money betting podcast game analyst for
CBS Westwood One also the Eagles on the
call for the Bengals and Ravens next
Sunday night on Westwood one I was
wondering why the NFL doesn't allow a
third quarterback on the sidelines so
you don't have saquon Barkley taking
Snaps uh can't you what's the big deal
if you have a practice squad quarterback
who's on the sidelines in uniform and
it's an emergency situation only the
only way he can get in is if the
quarterback is injured
is that kind of like the like the goalie
in hockey who sits up in the booth until
unless there's two goalies to ninja and
then the guy's like a plumber or
something and he goes out on the field I
don't know if he's a plumber but yeah
you're right but I love that
I love when the emergency uh goalie is
used I do think the NFL should consider
that I guess the counter argument is Dan
you're allowed to promote two guys from
practice squad now so you're allowed to
have 55 guys on the active roster you're
allowed to dress more than you ever used
to before I think the NFL is really
saying to people hey the onus is on you
to have three quarterbacks dressing like
the Dolphins did by the way Thursday
night Thursday night last Thursday
against the Bengals they activated
Skylar Thompson the rookie from Kansas
State to make sure they had three
quarterbacks eligible so I like where
your head's at Dan I think they probably
should consider that but if they don't
these teams need to think about it
because man we had Bailey zappy playing
you know we've had some interesting
quarterbacks out there sequence taking
direct snaps because you only have two
that guy's two snaps away then you have
Dan Daniel Jones well I think has a
pretty bad ankle sprain out there he
can't really protect himself that's
probably not real good uh not a real
good look for the league either
before I let you go I'm curious about
this with offense and defense you played
on the offensive line in the NFL if
you're the Lions offense
and then you run into the lions defense
let's say in the hallways or a meeting
room and does does it get contentious
because you're scoring
you know the highest scoring team in the
NFC and your defense is the worst
defense scoring wise in the NFC so what
what happens when when those two parties
collide
there can absolutely be tension and I've
experienced it and unfortunately it was
because the offense stunk that I was a
part of and the defense was awesome and
you just get some side-eyed looks you
can tell they're getting frustrated some
of the guys might start making comments
um I've seen that a couple times you
know there's not really another sport
like it right like you know I don't
think the baseball hit do the baseball
hitters get mad at the pitchers I don't
know but you know basketball's
continuous hockey's continuous soccer's
can like they're all part of it but
that's what makes football so unique
most of your meetings you're not even
together like there's defensive meetings
there's offensive meetings you're almost
separate teams and yeah the guys on
defense if they're I remember in Buffalo
I think was 2003 our defense was awesome
we were struggling on offense those guys
were getting very angry and you know I
didn't really blame them like I I I'd be
frustrated if I were those guys here
they're playing there you know what's
off and we can't put any points on the
board that that's when it's really the
coach's job
and the leader's job to really try to
keep the team together and remember
listen like it's not offense versus
defense we all have to do this thing
together to try to win games but
absolutely there can be tension I don't
know if Detroit's offense is good enough
yet I know they're scoring a bunch but I
don't know if those guys are this isn't
my home this isn't like the Chiefs your
bills offense where I think it's a
little premature for the Detroit guys on
offense to get mad at the Detroit
defense but maybe if it continues yeah
thank you buddy safe travels this week
always thank you Dan that's Ross Tucker
host of the Ross Tucker football podcast
joining us on behalf of DraftKings he'll
be on the call Bengals Ravens next
Sunday night that will be on radio on
Westwood One